what do you do once you've mastered
hitman you make it harder for yourself
i want to challenge those of you that
have gotten comfortable in the shoes of
agent 47
to turn off some of the game's hud and
other safety features
and i'm gonna argue why i think the game
is actually better without them
but i want to be clear that there is no
correct way to play hitman
and i'm in no way throwing shade if you
don't play this way or
even need these features in order to
play the game hud
elements are tools that can help people
and they're there for a reason
i just want to present the experience
that can be gained by removing them
because i think doing so shines an even
greater emphasis
on the game's fantastic design and
pushes you
to play differently so strap in hit the
like and sub button
and let's dive into the exciting world
of turning off menu settings
if there's one thing i'd love for you to
take away from this video
it's to try the game without mission
story guidance
the default hitman missions can be
solved in countless ways but they all
have
optional story missions which ask you to
perform a series of specific scripted
objectives
to trigger your targets into a situation
that conveniently leads to
murder well almost all of them we'll get
to that
when set to default as full the game
will give you
pretty clear details on what you need to
do to trigger
events for a particular story and will
give you a waypoint you just
need to follow it's a nice system for
those that need a helping hand early on
when still
learning how the game works but once you
understand things better you can switch
to
minimal which turns the waypoint off but
still gives you a
general clue as to what to do next this
is how i typically play the game as it
still guides me on what the game wants
to trigger the next part of the story
mission
but leaves me free to discover how to do
that on my own if you're feeling really
spicy you can completely turn it off
giving you
no hints whatsoever including disabling
the story mission menu
the story opportunities still exist but
they're no longer presented as obvious
objectives
they fade into the background as another
small part of the grand clockwork system
that makes up these levels and it's a
lot of fun to play this way
in fact if you've already played all the
way through hitman 3 you've had an
opportunity to try this for yourself
with the berlin mission
which has no handler and therefore no
story missions
however that mission still has scripted
moments that are absolutely
story like missions just without calling
them that and that's basically what
you're getting throughout the entire
experience
if you choose to turn mission story
guidance off
you'll find yourself soaking up
information eavesdropping on npcs
and parsing out any useful details you
can exploit
hot tip if you have subtitles on any
dialogue that shows up
usually contains a clue that can
potentially help you in some way
they are also smartly written to provide
you with all the information you need
for example in sapienza if you walk into
this hair salon
you'll overhear a conversation where an
employee is talking about his private
detective brother who is in town on a
case for francesca desantes
who is one of our targets naturally this
leads you to the conclusion that this pi
could help you get closer to her
and conveniently they mention where to
find him sleeping on a bench
a few blocks away so you explore the
surrounding area and
lo and behold there he is you can wake
him up with the radio
and then listen to his phone
conversation with francesca
where he plans to meet her by the pier
at which point
you might get the clever idea to knock
out the pi
and pretend to be him at the meeting now
if you were to follow
the guided instructions it still leads
to the same result
but that's just it you're following
instructions
you don't get that moment where you feel
clever for finding the detective
and thinking to yourself aha i should
disguise myself as him for the meeting
rather than just doing it because the
game told you to the guided objective
also leads you down the one path where
you can meet francesca
as the pi when this setup actually leads
to a whole host of solutions
you could leave the pi alone and stake
out the pier
gathering more information from their
conversation and then follow francesca
and see where she
goes you could place explosives at the
meeting point
or you could find a strategic stiper
vantage point on top of the church tower
or if you head to the ancient ruins
you'll find an
old cannon which just so happens to be
pointed at the pier
where the meeting is taking place
what's fun about these outcomes is that
you thought of them
it was your cleverness that put a plan
into
action the guides end up being the most
boring way to play hitman i'm glad they
exist
and i think they are a great tool to use
while still learning the ins and outs of
how hitman
works but once you feel comfortable i'd
recommend turning them off
the other big crutch you'll find
yourself relying on is instincts
or hitman vision at the press of a
button you can see enemy outlines
through
walls interactive objects and the
locations of your targets
at any time regardless of where you are
like with the story missions it's a
great addition to the series
first added in absolution to make it
more approachable
but once you start getting comfortable
and wanna
up the challenge you should turn it off
this will completely change the way you
approach stealth
learning guard patterns is more critical
and peeking around
corners before entering rooms becomes
vital
i'm not gonna lie it's gonna feel bad at
first it's
easy to become reliant on instincts
after using it for so long
and you're gonna keep hitting that
button like the video game equivalent of
a phantom limb
but what you get in its place is an
undeniably
satisfying stealth experience where you
need to not only plan out your approach
more carefully but also
take a leap of faith and be ready to
improvise
you also have more room for error than
you might think
enemy alert states still take enough
time to trigger that you can dart out of
their line of sight
run away to another part of the map and
the search will eventually be called off
having the godlike power to see through
walls is fun
but taking it away ups the thrill and
danger
it really makes you feel like you've
earned the hit
man sorry
honestly if you walk away from this
video and turn just story mission
guidance and
instincts off and call it good there i
am more than happy
thrilled even thank you so much for
willing to listen to what i had to say
and
try something new the removal of just
these two elements changes the game
quite a lot but if you're looking to
chase an even
higher thrill there's still plenty more
we can do
turning off instincts mode may remove
47's x-ray vision
but you still have a lot of that same
information on the minimap
you actually have a few options when it
comes to removing it
of course you can just disable it
outright but if you have trouble with
spatial awareness and need the minimap
you can also disable just the npc
and target indicators while still
keeping the mini map up as well as a
useful information
like letting you know you're trespassing
but now we get to the
real dangerous stuff npc icons are the
white little dots above a person's head
that tell you when they will see through
your disguise
turning this off makes the game
incredibly difficult
especially when it comes to enforcers
removing this
is perhaps a step too far for me
personally
where disabling features like story
guides works because the game offers
other ways to convey that information to
you in this case
you don't have any visual way of knowing
who will become suspicious of you
realistic sure but it pushes the game to
a level of hardcore
that becomes harder to recommend
same goes for the game's attention alert
indicator
but for the sake of this video we're
gonna turn it off
we'll also disable camera grids to make
it more difficult to avoid showing up on
surveillance footage
now let's see what else a picture in
picture
i don't really need that weapon hud
you know what why don't we just turn
everything off that uh
that is the purpose of this video after
all right and then
because i want to suffer i'll set the
difficulty to master
which adds extra cameras and enforcers
makes combat tougher and npcs more alert
to sound
getting blood on your outfit ruins the
disguise
and finally you only get one save and no
auto saves
let's see how i do to make it fair
i'm not going to do any of the story
missions that i i know how to do
i'm sorry it took so long but i had to
access our remote server to print
everything and i couldn't get my vpn to
oh i can definitely discuss
this guy
[Music]
aaron ford jr don yates is expecting me
okay right this way mr ford damn this is
too easy
[Music]
all right
[Music]
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry
no i should just knocked him out that
was rude that was really mean
put oh god
[Music]
are
[Music]
oh
saving here this is my safe point oh
[Music]
god
[Music]
let me know if you see any trespassers
will do sir
[Music]
it's done well i can safely say that was
one of the most
frustrating and yet rewarding stealth
experiences
of my life was it worth it as a one-time
experience i'd say yes
i don't think i could possibly handle
playing the whole game that way on the
regular
and i'd really only recommend it to the
most patient of players
but really that was me just having fun
with the most extreme of examples
the beauty of hitman is in its options
you can mix and match
any of these different features i've
talked about to find the best version of
hitman for you
what i hope is that this video has
encouraged you to break out of your
comfort zone and give some of these a
try
it might just make an already fantastic
game even better
i had a lot of fun making this video as
the hitman world of assassination
trilogy is one of my
favorite games period if you end up
giving
any of this a try let me know your
experience in the comments
one of my favorite parts about hitman is
the stories people share of their
spectacular successes or failed attempts
and i'd love to hear some catch you all
next time
[Music]
you